[Music]
what's up there reject nation we're
gonna watch ourselves the second episode
of superman lois as we're playing catch
up guys what we asked right now is if
you can go ahead and hit the like button
that help us out a lot with the
algorithm and the way it works subscribe
and click that notification bell to get
notified when our reaction for the next
superman lois is up here on the channel
i believe we're going to be uploading
them after episode 4 comes out we'll be
uploading them on thursday mornings
that's like the main goal right now so
yeah but we'll inform you we'll inform
you as always full-length watch along
where you sync up with the time code or
over at our patreon page become a super
eject today show your support by
checking out all the content we got to
offer over there lastly thanks to the
boys that prep for helping us set up
these down let's hop into action
[Music]
there's egg and bacon and sausage sorry
but i'm kind of vegan
okay i can whip up some oatmeal or slice
up some food i'm not really a big
breakfast person oh man oh god this
isn't done beerus always
messed up
yeah
was it lois is cooking
it's gas
indigestion jordan
he's fine
yeah for now
we have to figure out what's causing it
in case it starts to affect him too and
the other people in town who had
kryptonians we paid for this time george
and it's all yours no harm no foul well
looking forward to a little friendly
competition
ain't gonna be nothing friendly about it
playing dirty better conserve your
strength for the weight room
says the guy that can barely curl a
patty milk
that's why i switched up my whole
regimen kent
that's my time to shine
you're gross
oh jordan's still getting love from the
footballers sarah's dad just got her an
old muscle car so they can fix it up 7-8
firebird i think i mean it's a total
junker he can't even get the engine to
start no that's easy
well it's probably a clogged fuel filter
there just
haven't tried something like this okay
so here's the pump
go home and emasculate him like this
do you remember that piece you wrote
about the self-help guru ali alliston
it's back in the news again because of
this podcast that just came out ellie
alston's a cult leader this podcast says
you coursed some of your sources come on
i did everything by the book don't
always hmm
chrissy in the first line in that
article i disclosed that i had a
personal connection that a family member
had been involved in the cult and
whenever something has to do with your
family you have a different set of rules
look i know this seems big i get
attacked all the time it'll blow over i
promise
christy your newspaper's nothing without
lois you need a little controversy
good visibility on you
visiting morgan
maybe he knows something after keeping
him under some red sunlight here it must
be a kryptonian prison when a
consciousness is rejected by its host
can there be lingering effects take me
to my fortress and let me run some tests
this was a waste of time enjoy solitude
oh i will schedule
and you let him have tv
you'll be sentenced to read and like it
x kryptonite is what morgan edged used
to give people powers it'd be really
dangerous in the wrong hands exactly
amortec is doing a public service oh
okay
as soon as i have more information
you'll be my first call
right she's good she's good where's your
guy i don't know he's not answering my
texts
well you better show up soon or you're
gonna be the one talking for him ah plot
prediction i can't do it
i'm so sorry lana
my family needs this
i understand
you have to run lana
yep thank you for coming
but i'm afraid i have some bad news for
all of you lana's running
i asked natalie if she wanted to come
over after school to work on the car
hey
you should come it'll be fun cars aren't
really my thing
uh i'll take you later like 150 times
late later today
that's your chance man
clorox not who
whoa
cool
get them out of here
oh
yeah you knew someone was coming
oh the other superman no
not a good look
okay
he's got the same red crest and
everything too that guy phillip
karnowski drug runner weapon stealer
stole a large quantity of x kryptonite
from the shuster mines before we got
amritek in there he was selling xk what
can i say everybody wants superpowers
look you don't want to be part of my
team okay i get it but it means that
you're on your own so whatever
is going on i hope you figure it out
otherwise right now you're more of a
liability than a hero oh my god that guy
i wonder if you're up to this
tag harris
he's barely 18.
sure is fast isn't he nah he's he's a
good guy man
i don't know why you're talking totally
trustworthy i i'm sorry dean gets to
blame us for everything that happened
and then take the credit for the
windfall
so unfair it's just politics baby look
i'm sorry but i gotta go to work okay
come on we know where this is going
oh show me something ryan oh you want
more you got this come on
homie's on xk
i think tom might be able to help me you
can't go there with him by yourself let
me go with you
just to watch your back and plus his
girlfriend's blowing him off yeah he's
trying to keep him distracted
it's a family reunion
my son
what is that you
[Music]
you doing in his fortress and you are of
course you don't recognize your
forgotten son i had no knowledge of your
existence until it was too late you're
his mother oh yes
but i did not give birth to him all
children were engineered except for one
i've been having visions
and i believe they may be of the
destruction of krypton he also believes
they're caused by the eradicator then i
should be able to provide answers
i got such a good actor all right
did you learn how to do all this
oh i spent all my free time learning
mechanics in our bunker what are you and
your dad like doomsday peppers or
something no it's just what we call my
dad's shop doomsday
clues
oh my god you're a genius alex looks
like cool and awesome
kiss her
with a splash of almond milk oh he's
going for it oh dude that splash make it
happen
what's the best thing for nat what about
you
i'll make the adjustment i'm on bumble
see how she favors him your father
well yeah he's not a genocidal sociopath
who tried to destroy civilization
[Laughter]
from what i hear john's probably
stronger than you now
nice i came here to shit-talk you
you don't have any allies in this cave
okay something's breaking loose it's
definitely not
oh
[ __ ] damn it
you won't be able to stop
stay back
god damn it
so frustrating
[Laughter]
patterns i'm picking up aren't seismic
there's something causing this
joe i said to evacuate now
joe
joe do you copy
what the hell was that
common sense would say to evacuate now
there's something down here oh man
what the hell
run dude
what is that
hey
you are not your father tal
there is good in your heart you must let
the boy go
joe what are you doing
joe
oh god
no bueno whatever's down there i never
seen anything like it what is it
oh yeah
don't you ever touch him
mouth i never should have trusted you no
cal he was right to bring you here
i know what's wrong with you she
believes they're still good in you
do you feel the same
no
but i want to
come on man turn good those aren't
earthquakes there's something causing
them and we have to figure out get off
the goddamn podcast if your sister's the
one changing her story it doesn't matter
how right you were
public's never gonna believe you
lucy
you are what this town needs for mayor
i mean come on no one cares about
smallville like lana cushing
i just filled out the paperwork to make
it official
a couple months from now
i might be smallville's first first dude
rooting for it my friend
be that best first dude you can be what
happened to your shirt oh it uh
may have gotten ripped when i went head
to head with uncle jerk face what yeah i
know but the crazy thing is i actually
think i could have beat him up no way i
i landed a couple blows that's awesome
yeah
is everything okay
with sarah
ask yourself she's outside on the front
porch oh no he's ready to break up with
you
she's got a dear john letter down there
what could be her secret did she cheat i
kissed someone
called it last episode man her name's
aubry and she and i i i thought we were
just friends at first and then it just
sort of happened
that's even more confusing that's tricky
oh man it doesn't really matter
then why'd you do it that's what i'm
trying to tell you it just happened it
doesn't mean
anything thanks for telling me
i'll see you at school
jordan
oh
no perfect opportunity to laser her
blow her head up
deserves it
you get what you did his powers have
been growing i know but it doesn't
matter he's too young to be put in those
situations don't beat yourself up clark
there's no way you could have known your
brother got his powers back i think that
had a bit of a hunch you know
so like somebody might have picked that
up instead of just thinking of it as a
word
if your visions are linked to these
earthquakes and what your mom said is
true then whatever's down there is
what's causing this
i never would have thought that i still
don't see it
[Laughter]
something came through
and it's even more powerful than we
hoped
what is it
it's jesse eisenberg
yeah
show continues to be good john kick it
off with every problem you have
kick it off there tell you viewers who
is the entity below crowd just tell me
already that's your problem uh my
problems with the evidence come on just
focus on problems that's the structure
of reviews you lead with the problems
you talk about only negatives first
here's my venue how did nobody
think to go and i know that that uh
anderson said like hey we barely know
how to test kryptonian anything but uh
you know you're just gonna let morgan
edge be up in here saying ah i don't
have any more powers it's fine and then
everyone's just like
yeah it's fine just take him in his word
let's just go out to the place where he
can arguably have the best chance of
getting power back and hey we're just
gonna get sam lane to pull a few strings
and that's it
no yeah it's my only gripe about this
episode
like you don't have anything to test if
this guy has some power left yeah it's
true now it was like uh and this is not
surprising at all yeah
i would be like cautious the entire time
yeah i i would have
that is the only ground i feel like it
might have been a stronger choice not to
have him just immediately double cross
him there
i think um i think a gripe
if i had to nitpick okay
because yes
all right people look the bit is is that
you usually talk about positives first
before you go to negatives that's the
way you usually get yeah now i'm trying
to find something all right okay okay
nitpick
i thought it was like way obvious
whatever is happening and the minds is
connected to whatever's happening
superman and i thought they would have
put that together themselves a while ago
yeah that makes sense yeah like hey it
seems whenever some earthquake happens
it's you kind of freaking out
yeah i mean i i i appreciate the effort
of them going hey maybe it's something
to do with the eradicator like i
understand what is a nice conclusion
about that but at the same time it does
seem like no these are pretty well
coinciding yeah notice the earthquakes
and your seizures
but it's still some good stuff man it's
still good still waiting to see if the
season shapes up who plays morgan age
oh goodness i used to know that guy's
name i couldn't tell you the actor
anymore well he's phenomenal it looks
like we're getting that arc i i kind of
want them to really play with me here i
want them i don't want it to be like so
obvious of the path of yeah he's
definitely going into good territory i
want i want them to like play like a
little bit of a loki thing yeah you know
like the brother or you're not sure is
he gonna be good or not yeah and i want
them to really have fun with that
because we're loki's more
of like it's fun to watch him be that
way there's there's a lot more
something almost like shakespearean
about this guy's tragic
portrayal of him yeah then because he's
such a phenomenal actor that whenever
you give him a chance to monologue and
let out some pain it's so effective and
moving
and so i want uh i want them to have
some real fun with that like i like the
nuance of the mother laura laura being
like you know i see good in you such a
cliche a lot i see good in you
chaotic good
i don't ever once i want some i want a
villain to come back and be like i don't
see that there's anything wrong with
what i'm doing yeah
yeah exactly
that's the whole point i completely
believe in my cause i still want to
bring krypton back like good is
subjective you know and i want them to
i want sometimes i just want that retort
to come in
but uh yeah i love i like that but then
also kyle you know looking at him saying
no i don't see any good in you but you
can see that yearning you know that he
has a little bit more of a
down dejected type of portrayal uh tyler
has been doing this season around like
he kind of has a there's a bit of a
say he looks a little depressed yeah i'm
not saying like he's depressed to return
like that clark clark is depressed like
there's a lot of showings
yeah you can really see it in his
demeanor a lot it's not as uh chipper
superman as you like he's really being
isolated in all corners like he's the
dod's outing him he's feeling powerless
because like he can just succumb to
something that he doesn't know what the
cause is like this mysterious thing he's
getting replaced by super junior
superintendent yeah he's getting
replaced by them
uh he's obviously having family problems
at home so yeah dealing with that and i
mean all the storylines i'm really
enjoying uh lana
and kyle you know like the whole running
for mayor thing
some of this the direction has been kind
of obvious
however
despite the fact that plot points can
kind of go in an obvious way
it doesn't
the the the scene executions are always
touching and moving like when lana you
know
i i like the the reveal of like yeah i
came here and all the firefighting
buddies they signed
and supported you and then she like
eventually turned to the show like i
already made that decision like i really
like that like that she owns it and you
know i don't see you know it's like you
can kind of predict that like what he
has in his hand has something to do with
her running for mayor um but then for
her already i made that choice is really
moving and i'm really liking the way
that a relationship and seeing kyle not
just be like some [ __ ] jealous
see him in a position where they could
actually support each other and really
be a team yeah as a nice prospect and
also
natalie and sarah bonding with each
other they were gonna get together i was
getting like gay vibes from them in some
ways you know i think i even said
something yeah it's just a joke but i
didn't know but now
you can see a little bit of like sexual
chemistry between two
um
or like some type of romantic attraction
that could possibly occur
but yeah like showing like that side of
them that's really into like this stuff
that you don't normally see with girls
or if you do put it with girl it's
something like some [ __ ] megan fox
transformation yeah yes
oh it's still so sexy yeah let's do a
bunch of tracking shots around showing
her midriff as she fixes the car yeah no
nor are they like you know uh do it like
making it like hyper tomboy yeah yeah
yeah she's a believable girl who also
knows how to fix cars right right so i
enjoyed that those qualities to them and
watching theirs i like the idea of
pairing them up and what they've been
doing with
messing with the dynamics of you know
siphoning off
john and lois together and how that's
something that he has to constantly deal
with is trying to adjust like i just
constantly feels like
he's gonna go for it
he's gonna go in for that kiss here yeah
he's gonna make a move yeah
like it's it's a real conflicting
situation for him absolutely why
wouldn't you why wouldn't he be
conflicted about it especially for how
well they get along in this universe
yeah how nice she is tim all the time
he's got his daughter back there i get
my family going that [ __ ] superman's
absent a lot of people
yeah it's tricky
uh yeah so i do appreciate a lot of
these aspects i'm uh the the pluck that
seems so serious and intense and i'm
like i just kind of came left field uh
that i i'm hoping
turns into something worthwhile at least
emotionally because it's called superman
and lois right so
superman is you know obviously the man
of steel missions and that world
and then lois represents the family life
you know the personal life that's what i
think and also her own journey there's a
lot of layers to the titling at superman
lowest the good that can come from
humanity yeah well it's like the the
lowest part represents the family drama
but also she has her own solo adventures
as a journal investigative journalist
and then the superman side is you know
all the big single [ __ ] sci-fi shows
so i i like
i like that but but this storyline of
like the podcast is something brewing
and then oh she's getting outside i'm
like where's this
coming from all right like i know that's
kind of how it happens in real life it's
just we've never heard i don't recall
this story at all from season one yeah
and it's the kind of thing that feels
like it's a very relevant thing what
happens
yeah there's a piece of that that i i
appreciate like i like that they bother
to include you know the things going on
at the paper but i would like to feel
like you know there is a thrust like i
would like to see the two of them like
it was nice to see them at the mine
doing some actual current day
investigative journalism and part of me
it's like i'm open to the story line
with the podcast sure sure i'm sure they
will pay that off but right now it does
feel sort of like a side thing that
isn't really related to much of anything
else other than lois's you know general
mental state uh but you know i i am
hoping that that maybe develops into
something a bit more vital and a bit
more pertinent and and it doesn't spin
its wheels well
is
my my main issue is as soon as they're
that part of the show kind of feels like
they're forcing some drama they want us
to be like oh did lois do something
shady and messed up or maybe she didn't
cross all her
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah maybe she didn't do all that
uh
perhaps you know
it's a good point about like you play
different rules when it's your family
like she does yeah i and the thing with
christy that was kind of like
frustrating to me is like jesus woman
like you're just immediately like what
the [ __ ] is that
yeah well i mean chris is in a tough
position because it's like lois is she
has such a status and yet like it's
gonna be way worse for christie if
anything bad happens with her i know but
it's not like she even comes to her like
questions i would like where are you
yeah exactly it's like some nuance to
that exchange to at least uh indicate
the amount of growth and bonding they
went through last season like they've
been through a lot together like how
about some concern for lois yeah yeah
100 instead of just like i believe this
and i'm mad at you yeah
how about a little benefit of the
doubter like hey can we figure this out
you know are you yeah are you okay what
is this about you can talk to me we're
partners
yeah and then growing frustrated with
the lack of answers yeah who just made
instead of jumping right right too i
believe this podcast
yeah and i mean hey in the first episode
we were sitting there going oh god is
natalie going to become really annoying
this season and this episode was like
better great improvement on that and so
like i'm hoping yeah like with christy
that that will also sort of blossom and
develop
uh hopefully we got those you know
arguments out of the way this episode in
terms of that plot line i mean different
now i mean it's not like
i won't complain if they come back it's
just now it feels more layered yeah um
but then uh you know sarah cheating
oh boy you don't know what you cheated
on lady oh yes right yeah i've boy's got
temper problems
i mean he hasn't shown temper problems
lately he has it i mean yeah i i trust
him right now not to fly off the handle
and i i don't know this is like episode
four version of him
he's gonna beat her over jesus yeah he's
gonna fly her up high and drop her hand
uh no i i like that too of him being
like look dad i i really need to feel
like i can help somebody right now or be
important to somebody right now so i
as much as there is some like treachery
and being like yeah let's just all go to
this fortress together like i really
liked that for him this episode but yeah
i i wonder
how far they're gonna push jordan with
this it's a really real
way of handling cheating as a teenager
too i think uh-huh like that happened to
me when i was a kid uh i got i got i had
a girlfriend like 14 15 and then uh
she went back home for a little bit and
then some guy made a move on her
and then they look like had an orgy you
know
they sent me the videotape yeah
that was like a kiss that like this kiss
that it happened yeah and then it was
like something happened and i'm not
getting an answer i'm being pushed away
and and then uh and then eventually like
the truth came out like i was like
that's a really like real real
version of like how teenagers who
often have landed themselves in cheating
it's usually just a kiss yeah yeah oh
god what did i what did i do i was in
this yeah it's a whole other context
removed
and i mean i i do appreciate the the
layer that yeah like it is with a girl
so there's that extra layer of like okay
this this must be sort of uh
more emotion i feel like it was just
like oh i kissed another guy it might
have led to a more cut and dried
exchange i do think though like i i'm i
i do
i'm constantly like uh you know one
who's oh like you've probably if you've
really followed this channel probably
heard me say like a gazillion times that
if
you know i think a big key in in you
know helping out with
portrayal of the lgbtq community
whatever is that
just normalize it right and normalize it
however i do think that they should
expose to know how to
show a whole scene of it no i i think
though if you are a teenager if that is
your first sexual experience with
another girl then you cheated i think
there would be some like questions that
would arise what is my yeah what am i
really into and what is my taste really
yeah what do i need
my first response would have been 3k
like honestly like i would have been
trying to tell
just immediately turned jordan into a
creep
cool can i come next time what camper
you're going to
yeah yeah i think uh
because especially as a teenager time
you know uh that that can definitely be
something that is uh very conflicting
and fun
yeah you know but same time on the flip
side i do like that they also didn't
make it about there's also the other
side of me that i like that i just made
it about the immediate situation of just
them
like she cheated yeah and then he's got
to deal with that yeah and then the way
because i like the realistic portrayal
of it of how he was feeling like he
[ __ ] up when he really didn't do
anything wrong well they're really good
too at portraying
you know the whole thing with jordan
like the whole thing about like ah you
know i'm trying to be cool and even just
the small talk that they're making it
really does smack of one of those guys
who's like wow i i got somebody who i
really care about who's like way out of
my league and i really want to keep her
but now i'm almost kind of awkward in
the way that i try and do that yeah you
know as much as she is giving out you
know like kind of uh you know closed off
signals to him he is also trying really
hard true they make that very natural
yeah i think uh i thought that was
actually really well handled and um
i think there's a lot of layers to
impact there but yeah it's a good show
still still good jonathan is still the
best guy ever i remember
but this point in episode two of season
one i was like wow this is [ __ ]
cheap yeah
where has this been
i haven't quite got there with this
season yes it's still good like it's
it's still good it's still good yeah um
but i still feel like they're really
building something up whereas i felt
like with last season but like at the
end of episode one i was like what a
phenomenal show yeah
yeah
yeah maybe waiting for yeah that big
sort of like okay now we are really
firing on all still it still feels like
there's a bit of place setting here true
true all right guys well that's where
we're at right now i gotta watch episode
three get that up in a couple days too
uh but in the meantime subscribe leave
your thoughts down below
and you know only talk about the things
you don't agree with us yeah yeah call
us out it's the way to engage and
antagonize us in the comments almost a
45-minute video just you know
just only point out the one thing hit on
the one thing we missed one thing we
missed or you didn't like that we did it
yeah so let's talk about that and if we
didn't talk about it we definitely
missed it intended yeah
[Music]